انتفاضه بدات بصوت النسائي وكانت النساء
اولى ضحاياها مقتل مهسى اميني كان شراره
التظاهرات في ايران واستمرت الحركه
الشعبيه في البلاد لتكون المراه متصدره
المشهد
تزامنا مع يوم المراه العالمي وتلبيه
لدعوه الناشطات النسويات اتجهت نساء ايران
الى الشوارع منددات بممارسات النظام
القمعيه بحق المراه على وجه التحديد
رقم محاولات نسائي في ايران تحصيل حقوقهن
بهدف الحريه لم يستطعنا حتى الان تحقيق
ذلك السبب يعود الى ممارسه النظام
الايراني وقوانينه التي تقمع النساء
لم تعب حوادث وتسميم الطالبات في ايران عن
اللافتات بعد الجدل الذي اثرته تلك
الحوادث واختلاف الروايات حولها فمن جهه
المعرضه الايرانيه تتهم النظام بتلك
الممارسات وسط مطالبات دوليه بالتحقيق
فيها بينما يصر النظام الايراني على روايه
المؤامره وانخراط متظاهرين في تصميم
الطالبات
عمليات التسمم المستمره منذ ثلاثه اشهر لم
تترك اي مجال للشك في انها منظمه ويتم
تنفيذ هذه الجريمه حسب الاوامر خامنئي
ينتقموا من فتيات ايران اللواتي العبن
دورا حاسما في الانتفاضه الاخيره ويريد
ترهيبهن
قمع وقتل وتعذيب وتسميم ممارسات ليست
غريبه عن النظام الايراني بحق شعبه عامه
والنساء خاصه اسماء كثيره كانت ضحيه
ونداءات دوليه تطالب النظام بوقف العنف
ومحاسبته على تلك الانتهاكات اذا عمر
العربيه